hello everyone the nerd medic here and
you're watching animated biology with
urban so in this video of biomedicine
series we will learn about an
investigation known as mammography so
mammography is a technique used to
visualize the breast tissue and helps us
to detect lesions such as the breast
cancer now mammography is a very
non-invasive technique and it utilizes
low dose x-rays
now how mammography works
now when you go to a mammography clinic
a mammography unit is used
for breast and has specialized
accessories to limit the extra exposure
to the breast only
and a machine has a feature which holds
and compresses breasts into different
angles and positions so that the
technician can capture images of the
breast in different angles
and this allows to breast assume a
uniform thickness and gets a clear cut
picture
now let us understand how x-rays
are used in mammography now in a
conventional x-ray we have a x-ray tube
where from a cathode we fire fast
electrons towards an anode and that
electrons when hit the anode release
x-rays in mammography also we utilize a
similar mechanism but how we generate
low-dose x-rays is by means of using a
molybdenum anode
now let us understand what are the views
of a mammography based on compression of
the breast tissue we can have two sorts
of view one is known as a craniocaudal
view
also known as cc view and another one is
a medial lateral oblique view also known
as mlo view
now in craniocardial view the x-ray beam
travels from the cranial that is headed
to the cortal that is tailing and in
case of a mlo view the x-ray beam
travels from medial to lateral in an
oblique fashion
now in cranial water view the image
obtained somehow looks like this now in
this you can clearly make out the
contour of the breast the skin overlying
the breast the nipple areolar complex
and also you can beautifully see the
lactiferous ductile of systems of the
breast
in medial lateral oblique view in
addition to the contour of the breast
the nipple arugula complex and the
lactiferous ductular system you can see
another structure which is the
pectoralis muscles now why it is
important to look for the pectoralis
muscles we will come to that in a bit
now let us see how mammography is used
to study breast cancers
now in a cranioportal view on the left
hand side we have the normal breast on
the other hand in the right hand side we
have a breast which shows a dense
irregular mass
and signs of micro calcification these
two findings are very characteristics of
of breast cancer
on the other hand if we take an mlo view
on the
left hand side we have the normal mlo
view but on the right hand side in
addition to the dense irregular mass we
can see that along the pectoralis
muscles we have certain
masses and these masses represent the
axillary lymph node now involvement of
axillary lymph node in a breast cancer
can help in the staging and grading of
the breast cancer so it is very
important to look for axillary lymph
nodes and visualization of the
pectoralis muscle helps us to find and
look for auxiliary lymph nodes in a
mammography and this is the importance
of seeing a pectoralis muscle and the
use of mlo view
by now i believe you have understood the
basic concepts of a mammography now
mammography is a very useful tool for
screening of breast cancer and it can
detect presence of a breast cancer as
early as three years before the lump can
be palpated on the breast
so i believe you have enjoyed this video
if you have enjoyed this video please
hit that like button share this video
with your friends and peers of your
medical school and by any chance if you
are new to the channel please hit the
subscribe button and press the bell icon
so that you never ever miss a video from
our channel
also for high quality notes and flash
cards follow our instagram page animated
biology with arpan the link will be in
the description below
and you can also support our channel so
that we can continue to create high
quality educational content for free by
contributing to our us in the patreon
page also you can utilize the super
thanks icon to support our channel which
you can find in the bottom right corner
of the video in the super thanks you can
contribute using paytm paypal or upi
now if you want to get in touch with
arpan the links will be given in the
description box below and also for
medicine related content you can follow
me the nerd medic on my youtube channel
and you can also get in touch with me
via the following social media handle
links
until then bye bye see you in the next
one